ارامكو انسابقا معادن اوبتين ادوارد فيرست
اند فندمكيشن المانيا
ان معادن اللفت ديكنجم 199
كان هناك تصريح لفه لمسؤول من المكتب
الرئاسي الكوري
تحدث بان هذه الزياره سوف تركز على ثلاثه
مواضيع في المحادثات ما بين السعوديين
والكوريين الموضوع الاول البنيه التحتيه
الخاصه بالمدن مثل نيوم الموضوع الثاني
الطاقه بجميع انواعها النظيفه والطاقه
السلميه النوويه همم والطاقه التقليديه
همم بالاضافه الى الصناعات العسكريه همم
الحديث عن عن نيوم وعن همم الفرس التي
ممكن ان توفرها نيوم للشركات الكوريه همم
الكبيره
هو مصدر مصدر جذب ااا كبير جدا
الكوريين يبدو ان شهيتهم مفتوحه تجاه هذه
المشاريع بشكل كبير ايضا الصحافه الكوريه
تحدثت عن ان ولي العهد السعودي سوف يجتمع
مع رؤساء التنفيذيين لكبرى الشركات
الكوريه مثل سامسونج وهونداي وهاني واسكي
كل هذه المشاريع حسب ما تتحدث به الصحافه
الكوريه همم سوف يتم الحديث فيها عن الفرص
الموجوده في يوم همم ايضا هناك حديث عن
اجتماع لمجلس اداره اس اويل همم سوف يتم
خلال زياده ولي العهد الى كوريا همم وقد
يتم همم بعد هذا الاجتماع الاعلان عن
انشاء مجمع همم صناعي بتكلفه خمسه مليارات
دولار ينتج الاثيلين في في كوريا